yeah can we do a wave that way let's
test it three two one
see the back it's like you're not
listening
can you hear me
can you see me because I can see you all
the way there at the back chilling next
to the booth
right let's do this one more time we'll
do a wave I know usually it goes this
way
but from my field of vision it looks
beautiful
it's like a bowling ball
right
should we try it three three two one
yeah baby that's so cool
okay
back to the football
I think USA will Score first but I think
also the England will win I could be
wrong
I could be wrong
these are just my opinions someone who
knows nothing about football
so shall we go back live to our bait
Stadium
for England and USA
it is a favoring
to say the least some of the experiences
at the people at talk about in their
time include discrimination and accident
as well and the London Fire commissioner
Nancy Rowe has given a statement to say
that today is a very sobering day
there's no place of discrimination
harassment and bullying in the Brigade
from today it will be completely clear
to all staff what behavior isn't
acceptable and what the consequences
will be for that behavior he goes on to
say I'm deeply sorry for the harm that
that has been called
so Apache right gets the ball rolling in
the
second half in the United States
certainly having the better of the first
regrets not
actually that one great opportunity for
Western McKinney
and just to find a few warning shots
before the interval and although it's
been a long way from vintage from their
point of view
create opportunities
yeah he's been a sick and moose has
passed out for Robinson
U.S captain
no sir now Robinson
rice
let's see in that part I think where he
loves to be
talking
potatoes
Robinson
try shown by trippiot
the U.S starting in exactly the manner
they would wish McKinney
Robinson
and there is Adams and as Captain he's
actually a voted Captain by his
teammates well that could be very
interesting from the Zimmerman
a bit Lively
I'll just keep me on your toes
I don't know it actually drifted out
he's going to offer it's him and an
angle so he could just roll it
I'll just assumed he was in his
between the posts and then I was never
assumed never assume ever
foreign
hunting
rice
I think that when rice is really
underrated with the evidence Harry
MaGuire who headed in
so good
and there's Luke short to take the throw
Sterling
trivia
sucker available
right is there with him
what's arriving in the middle only
pulisic at the moment although where's
there
a little Cannon for McKenney
big chance
that now all started from that Challenge
from Anthony Robertson thief in his own
territory eventually coming out to [ __ ]
right here Stefan inside could brought
from John Stones
and Western McKinney doesn't really get
that out from under his feet and in the
end
it's underneath it far too much and
disguise it but
us press initially deep in their own
territory and
really quick across the ground
any of their last five World Cup matches
when it's been goless at half time
Ecuador in 2006 in the round of
16 in Germany was the last time they did
there's a fellow in a stadium every
single already who remembers that well
certainly Mr David Beckham
Over The Line
surely
read by Robinson
that's about the heat stirring though
they see just a little Gap
a little window of opportunity is just
darting in there good play fermenting
Robinson to benign
yeah for all these Road running in the
first game and some of his defensive
contributions have been most impressive
defending and starting attacks
mount
cider items
pretty
Making Tracks of the flank
units
born in New York his parents from Ghana
were actually on holiday visiting
relatives at the time
that's how he qualifies to play for the
United States
there's plenty of competition for his
Services I know Gareth Southgate would
like to have him available but
he was part of
being on scene up to under 18 level
coaching the Arsenal Academy was asked
what did you think when you first saw
him he said wow
wack would have said similar about this
guy sucker Tyler Adams
foreign
at you with
it's around him but
fantastic work again from Adam's there
to deny him
buyers charge
running power of Timothy Ware and indeed
Luke Shaw demonstrated
I think very much the message from
Dallas Southgate come on you must say
half time let's start
let's start playing with a bit more
Authority ourselves it's probably a bit
more confidence
it's not easy when you're
continually being hunted as they are
this evening
the team will grow that's a good
touching things like that can happen
with players step out of positions
and the space open up wide isn't it it
really did that
two Marine went for chasing
I was concerned over Timothy weyer here
and there'll be concern
recall measure in Liberia where his
father is President and their
clumsy challenge there from Luke Shaw
and Wells Timothy where are the shoes
this one
it's a bad challenge that you know it's
not a good tackle there at all look sure
he's gone in a little bit stands up and
it was always second best I think I get
in there
I can just
get away with that the referee says as
they're coming together
a little bit higher
and of course our president of the
Liberia and the
football fans of that Nation following
Timothy Blair and Alfonso Davis of
Canada as though
they were watching a Liberian team
tears in the eyes of 20 when he scored
against Wales
rice to spread it sure
away from the pressure of the Kenny
okay and dropping deep to influence
things
mount
Maguire now to start us
[Music]
all the time you go sideways you give
your opponent a chance to to get
organized
trees
this trip yet Bellingham making
it's a useful data in the inside right
position there
sure
rice
stones
and for pain but it'll break kind of for
the sick
just through the crowd the referee
sympathetic to his bright and a free
kick
to the United States
hole up and I think that's very
important to their game when they're
trying to do that they're just not
connecting enough
situations in the first half where they
did it go in behind
the US Bank line
too often I think they're going a little
bit too sideways and slow with stones to
Maguire to Bryce to Bellingham are
backwards
I think they've got to pick it up a
little bit I'd like to see one or two of
them taking people on going past their
opposite number
the minute you start doing that there's
gaps start to appear opportunities for
others happen
you're going in across the field and in
front of opponents particularly one like
this American team that's very well
organized it can frustrate you
foreign
crucial intervention that
again that's really good play once more
in the U.S to where they got in behind
patient build up and then when the
chance to play forward and play
accurately
I did it very well there
just able to
shrug off Sterling
and his walker Zimmerman
the longer the situation remains like
this
Echoes of
1950 may come to mind it states famously
breathe England in the World Cup it's
for the sea
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
that
Canary Maguire
had to put his head on that
watch Zimmerman on the penalty spot
peeling out around the back there's a
little block they're working very well
but Maguire stay strong and steadfast
and make sure
she's like perfectly on that ball
the value of
especially Southeast coach Illustrated
and
there's a lot of bumping and barging
these days that goes into it there's a
lot of blocks they're quite
sophisticated these Corners now the way
that they're constructed
Touch of NBA inspiration in there I'm
sure it's Robinson
and the U.S are getting on top again
[Applause]
forward ahead of the ball they're doing
it very well and their fans just sense
this is their moment now it matches when
you're having that a little bit you've
got to make it count
they'll certainly having a better of it
isn't threatening one it's really trying
to keep it alive look Kelly beaten to it
by sure good work by Adams there this is
full of six and Harry Kane back there
defending got his timing right
despite the shouts from behind the goal
really good coming as they are talking
Victor doesn't want to come and get them
it's not his strength coming out
soon
trying to grab it
and he wants to let those Center Arms
get on with him but they're coming right
in under his bar
I'm gonna go out of there again
it's dream now who is it
high on the ball from England's captain
[Applause]
Harry Kane hoping to turn defense into
attack but the pressure for the U.S can
build against that counter press there
is again you saw it Harry came on the
ball
poor blue shirt
blue shirt very good play once more look
now they pick the ball up now they take
the collective breather they get back
into their shape getting ready to go
again
rest in possession
quarterback
best
and Musa
again right just drifting in and out
now there's a bit of space for this to
move into
and he now has to come inside
and come inside very effectively but
they're sick might run to the right
way finally by trippier
well there's no vowels to replace the
pressure here playing and they can't get
out come on I can't pick that second
floor up and hit the US on the counter
[Applause]
everywhere
currently on the Move Tyler Adams and
making sure those anticipated reading
steal that is
over to recycle it for your team
you can't imagine China Adam has ever
been intimidated by anything he was
asked if england did intimidate him he
said he was more scared of spiders
foreign
[Applause]
England mines and bodies on the Stray
U.S full of confidence
and growing belief
and a threatening one again which left
Pickford Flappy but he did get a touch
on it
just never looks comfortable with those
sort of deliveries that are coming
and their bodies in and around enjoying
Bigfoot just not quite sure what's
behind him quite rightly
don't get away doing the next one
[Applause]
so different tests for now showing you
now
I can even quite get the meaningful
contact he was searching for
getting full contact
contemporary Zion
returning from your best and a free kick
for England pressure off
View at last they will say
this
is developing into a really really good
U.S performance and they need an
experience around England to try and
change that Jordan Henderson discussing
matters and is impending involvement I'm
sure we're going Southgate I'll just
think in our South game just wants his
team to to have more of the ball
American half of the field just
being able to do that
these guys at the back have done this a
lot they've been allowed to do that
that's not a threat to great ball
autistic when it's uh forward there's
always pressure in and around that ball
so maybe Jordan Henderson can come on
and just try and
just keep it a little bit 10 yard passes
in American territory again there face
and mouth starting to get frustrated you
start to force things they're always
trying to perhaps look for something a
little too intricate and elaborate
I'm really sure so getting ready the
impact substitute for the goal
against Iran Bellingham
hurricane caught on the Hop a little
there
and he gets a touch of the ball he
hasn't had very many Sterling's involved
it's a good area
[Applause]
[Applause]
to work again by uh
Western McKinney
yeah I'm not surprised that Carousel is
going to make changes too
so Jacqueline is great ball carrier
someone who will will try and take
people
or grab their room for some
information as I mentioned during the
innocent to keep things ticking over
better than they have been so far
they weren't there by Robinson again
great energy levels from America safe
and really good
way out
also called himself rather than anybody
else there
even a smooth sentence
to
imminent England substitutes just taking
some fluid on board and the briefing
about set-piece duties from Paul Nevin
for the former managers on the uh
England coaching staff Paul Nevin and
the Steve Holland
Hungarian Sunfish right hand men
that's done the top job somewhere
and it's the end of the evening for
Raheem Sterling
be replaced by Jack greenish
yeah you couldn't really make anything
happen tonight for him Sterling it's a
little bit tonight like he has done in
the Chelsea show this season it's not
being honestly
I mean it looks like
foreign
a few pointers on board
but what a contrast would you've been
against the star of the show against the
Islamic Republic of Iran but certainly
not an imposing figure in this
particular contest
Henderson well if nothing else to be
vocal
this is short England on the offensive
ream on the defensive
and a solid header
okay
hurricane
has had only one touch in the United
States penalty here he's had three in
his own tonight
save something where he can shift that
hole in his
hit so far
rice
now greenish
different challenge now for deaths and
they dare not touch him here
and forget their challenge is absolutely
right
greelish
train run out to steam in the end lucky
nearly
you do that grease though clearly he's
gone on with that message very much
lines
get out here and take them all
those in white
that was a soft free kick on how do you
ride
a referee very conspicuous in
fluorescent orange
about his decision
well regardless of the outcome the
United States
feel necessary to beat Iran in the final
group game
and they famously lost during the 98
World Cup
dashed on the charge
I'm lucky he had just released that
reflection earlier
you know there's the activity wire in
front of him
extra great intensity from the US
shortly going to make their first
edition of fresh legs Brendan Aaronson
another with an English Connection place
for Leeds United in the Premier League
in his kit although it would seem that
he's maybe going to shove a bib on here
and
our evidence his arrival is well he's
getting ever closer he came on in the
first game against Wales
just under 20 minutes or the 90
remaining England are yet to muster an
attempt on goal in this second half of
the Alabama Stadium
mount
a relish
just
[Applause]
not just busy from Mount to make that
angle this is good football it's really
back for Kane the foot in from Western
McKinney and weigh it
Maguire's there to challenge Harry
McGuire
suddenly a sense of Something Brewing
for England it's greenish
Henderson sure
rice
pre attacking his eye off the ball
to collector's item
to a steak and rice though you can see
him there in the middle of the screen
just in that holding position now
greenish mouth
and Jordan Henderson all trying to make
those runs further forward
nothing wrong with mixing I'm going a
little bit longer now again as well for
everyone haven't really done that
English voice is really quiet for the
World Cup finals and they're trying to
lift their team at the moment
however way has said happens to McKinney
Who the sick
crowded out rice
okay making a burst here but uh greenish
will bring Mountain to proceedings
Shores on hand as well
by the referee for a moment
rice
trippier
Bryce again
that's a better possession is for
England
well I just wonder if they started to
sense that they've weathered a bit of a
storm and are they now gonna step
forward and come into perhaps the best
moment of the game for them
sure
the mount
Shaka trippier
sucker again
there's Robinson's rice for the touch
McGuire Mount Kane
green preventing him from finding that
little pocket of space and then firing
it against sucker
and he's had a long Waits down there but
that at last is the cue for Brendan
Aronson to make his entrance here for
the United States
this record the school within Lincoln
and I are coming on against Iran is also
imminent for England
so Western McKinney as I mentioned a
little earlier is just making his way
back from injury has run his race again
longer this time
okay very well tonight
certainly has worked exceptionally hard
now we'll see how the dynamic change
late and again there's always more room
on the field
for England
they may feel now that they can start to
make better use or perhaps
it's really start to appear out here
that's shacklemore I named after the
great basketball legend Shaquille O'Neal
he's going to replace the junior desk
who we saw
struggling a touch
up his uh
it's only at this point not to a place
for risks if that election
and that's what they'll be telling him
whether he likes it or not
we have one glimmer of an opportunity in
the first half with Kyle Sackett
but he will not
be scoring on the successive World Cup
appearances
reverse the boys to Marcus rashford who
scored against Iran and it was
first touches in an England shirt since
that penalty in the European
Championship final at Wembley last year
when
England's trumps are claiming the first
Continental Crown evaporated
or the United States
two Leeds United players on the field
now who is sick
no just a little too intricate wasn't he
there from Christian courtesy
okay he's just trying to
thread of five yard forward pass there
I'm not submitted at times really sick
that he overthinks his game and that
feels
the burden that the correct by halter
has destroyed itself
having to carry the team in every moment
he's reassuring him that
that responsibility is not totally his
there are others out there to share it
but every match he walks into in the U.S
shirt is
carrying a huge amount of expectations
and that's some freshness and
determination from more but across the
line
and so is the
little disagreement that's broken out
there between him and Jack reeling
of Manchester City
more of Nashville
mount
some energetic defending who they see
a bit about this break it's way up and
acquire across
feeling it a little
reach for that one there didn't you
Harry MaGuire good defend himself in
there golly nice and quick
standing that hip a little bit there
is more
where
that's a tough nut to crack at this
stage of World Cup competition when they
lost only one of the last seven group
games
rice
so the ball are in a good area England
they're good pressure
Connor Adams it was for the probably for
the first time tonight got his pocket
fixed and
There's an opportunity with a couple of
clever passes that they might have been
able to really get at the U.S back line
ouch
one way to change the picture
turned on neatly by Kane to trip yet
Henderson on hand
and that should be Turners even with the
pressure
[Applause]
I'm also getting there ahead of
Tottenham
yeah this is the case in the Premier
League table at the moment
I'm just upset a lot of talking fans
there then
my 10 minute monologue about Jimmy
Greaves coming up
here's what
yeah
our instruments more
and it was sure
held by the full back of the US and
they're introducing
a couple of other players with English
connections
as dad looks on President George
Timothy goes off
[Applause]
to be replaced by a Geo Arena
whose father was born in England's
Northeast in Sunland where he fly this
trade there's a very distinguished
footballer also played for Manchester
City
and Josh sergeant of Norwich City in
England's second tier
also comes on
in attendance
Arena
their plate was part of the squad in
three World Cups didn't actually get on
any one of them
I think England would like to try and
get Marcus rashford involved and if
you're more than they have up to now
hasn't really seen it
I'll play Anthony Robinson very well
played
well one thing is for sure his energy
reserves are not going to deplete but
lack of care and possession
across the United States and the
Challenger the
chief clumsiness to it from more on
greenish yeah
it's a straightforward pass that
actually for shackle and gave the ball
away
and they can't just something up from a
free kick
always as I mentioned earlier it's
always look like just if the delivery is
right
well this had to be more late
disappointment to the United States
Shores delivery
in reading the situation
in customary fashion
dealt with that very well actually
Tiffany it's Harry MaGuire have made a
good run
from a DOT between those blue shirts to
get in and around the penalty spot but
I didn't really watch that all the way
and cleared that well yeah the cult here
of Craven Cottage the ever welcoming
home of Fulham Football Club is closing
in on a crucial clean sheet
are there any issues in World Cup
history You've Won and niches you don't
in England have one that you don't they
have recorded more Mill draws than any
other team in the World Cup finals 11th
one thing they haven't done tonight and
they haven't taken people on I don't
think enough at the top of the field
recall
too many white shirts really running out
the blue shirts and going Beyond them
and dragging somebody else out of
position and really stretches them
they always look like they could cope up
to mouth
I know that there's going to be probably
a healthy number of minutes at it
think that's something after is it down
south guys we want to look at I'm sure
he'd remind his players that
the top of the field they've got some
very clever footballers some really good
players
and they've got to be brave and they've
got to look to really take people on
to whose name can be heard
about the Elevate Stadium
certainly had the edge in terms of
attempts but goalkeepers not really had
to distinguish themselves tonight
only blew around him really
but here's grealish
and now rashford again
when he set his sights
well that was an attack on target
lucky could run from Luke's around him
which gives
us an opportunity there to just
fine put something towards the goal and
again you might have been able to get a
chance to take it out of his feet a
little bit more
before hitting it
well it's not a
score line that will be greeted with a
rapturous reception in England by any
stretch of the imagination but
cops are tough yeah and they probably
needed a game like this I think so you
need a test you don't want to March
through your the groups
without ever really breaking sweat
they've certainly had to work tonight in
boom they really have
but they'll also know from the back of
this performance that they're going to
find another gear from somewhere in
these summer moments these tough games
where you've got to grind it out there's
Raina
now I'm acquired a strive forward
haven't seen that
too often tonight
cinnamon and that's the matter in hand
for the U.S
okay
more
generally struggles
who is he Aaronson
more
from his Fizzles out one option there
from Shack Hall
going across that six yard line he's
looking for a cutback
he's made a great run and he's got
himself into a good position but
one decision
quite the same Pace in attack now
address sergeants are very busy player
strong Runner
as an eye for goal as he's demonstrated
for Norwich this season a good deal more
than he did last in the exalted clients
of the Premier League
that's the pressure here for the green
Cool Hand Luke brilliant
just simply
disappointed that they order the free
Kick the foul on Jordan Henderson yeah I
think he's stuck in there Jordan
Anderson to find a way out
that particular situation
might have been dripped a little bit
side of his leg
or is that
sorry
England where they want to be asking a
question trippier where he wants to be
over a set piece
for their good success in World Cups
and Corners with the big guys on the
penalty spot making various runs and
trying to block and just create a
Liliana space for someone to really go
and attack it
[Music]
oh my buyers in there
he never quite got free
[Applause]
raffle the crossfire against Iran in the
first game
as Christian pulisic has here
this is Aaron Seth
well the U.S mission statement would
have been surely to
I think it doesn't really unless they
get a win in these last few seconds
change too much going into the final
game what it will give them
is even more confidence even more belief
but mistakes like that one it was
Zimmerman's era it's grealish now for
England
and will Marshall there by Tyler Adams
the fellow by Musa
and these are free picks you can't
really afford to be giving away if you
like the United States or corporate from
Zimmerman
risking giving the ball aways
you know a couple of minutes left the
best now on the Block
free kicks
and really hurt you at this stage so
you'll be very keen Cinema I'm sure to
get his head on this
[Applause]
Luke Shaw presiding
anxiety a balance
he's gonna sneak around that boat how's
Harry MaGuire I even creep along the
edge of the 18 yard line
trying to Dart between those three
shirts gonna stay on side of course
[Music]
big chance that and it fell to the right
man hurricane made great contact with it
didn't he
really could pull in there
for him is a big opportunity
it's a great chance for Harry Kane
you've got to hit the target from there
and if he had off it's got a real Pace
on that head-on Matt Turner would have
been in serious fogger with that
one of the man who sets the highest
standards in front of goal will be
desperately disappointed with that Matt
Turner really relieved
I have to say it would have been very
harsh on the United States if they were
to lose this game
glance to the watch of the referee
and maybe they will have one more chance
to win it it's Rainer who's found
sorry that I think
so don't clatter into Rayna there
because you're right it looks like
Henry and Zimmerman flying forward
and just making sure that that back door
is firmly shut we'll take a point and
have taken a point at the start of the
night where he'd love
a decent delivery here to get one of
these big guys a chance to go and hit it
there's something different up there
Steve that's
let's be kind and call that intriguing
cannot believe they didn't command a box
well the spoil shared a point of beast
but it's the United States who will
emerge with a bigger slab of the credit
that's for sure
Christian pulisic shot rattling the bar
the closest score in that first half
United States certainly the better side
than Harry Kane though missed a great
chance just before the end to win it and
seal qualification foreign
a result that means it's all still to
play for in this group
FIFA plant Festival
[Music]
zero zero
my predictions are wrong I don't need to
get upset
but that's it for Group B
you want to notice that means a group b
England
top of the group
after winning against